وما زلنا في نفس الموضوع الجدل على نظام
التقاعد لا يقتصر طبعا على فرنسا لكن
اتخاذ اتخذ اشكال مختلفه من المواجهه بين
الحكومه ونقابات لكنه ايضا في عده دول
اخرى لان العالم كما نعلم بوجه التحولا
الديموغرافيا كبيرا يتوقع ان يتضاعف فيه
عدد الاشخاص
الذين يصلون سن التقاعد في العقود المقبل
وهذا طبعا يضغط على انظمه التقاعد صحيح
يمكن ان يصل الى قرابه مليار وست مئه
مليون شخص بحلول عام 2050 مثلا وبحسب مؤشر
العالمي للتقاعد لعام 2022 تحتل النرويج
الصداره في قائمه افضل عشر دول لامن
التقاعد العالمي لعام 2022
الولايات المتحده تاتي في المرتبه السابعه
عشر من حيث رفاهيه المتقاعدين بحسب تقرير
مؤشر التقاعد العالميه ارتفاع التضخم
حاليا في مقدمه الاسباب التي تق وراء
تعديلي انظمه التقاعد في عده دول بعدما
تاكلت القدره الشرائيه لاولئك الذين ما
زالوا يخططون للحياه بعد العمل
ان تواجهوا
على سبيل تغييرا ديموغرافيا يتسبب في ضغوط
على صناديق التقاعد ويجري الحديث غالبا عن
حل هو التقاعد في سن السبعين الصين تخطط
لرفع سن التقاعد بشكل تدريجي وعلى مراحل
التعامل مع زياره اعداد كبار السن في
البلاد ووفقا لمؤشر المعاشات التقاعديه
العالمي مارسر سي اف اي لعام 2022
اظهرت دراسه بان ايسلندا وهولندا
والدنمارك لديها افضل انظمه التقاعد في
العالم
وفي دول العربيه تجري حاليا نقاشات حول
تعديل انظمه التقاعد فيها وذلك في اطار
خطوات تستهدف سد العجز الذي تعاني منه
صناديق التقاعد وتشير تقارير البنك الدولي
لان انظمه التقاعد العربيه تغطي 35% فقط
من السكان
من عمان تنضم الينا الدكتوره رولا عواد
الاخصائيه اخصائيه هندسه البشريه وموجهه
موجهه شخصيه ومهنيه مشكله التقاعد مشكله
عالميه
لكن
يعني على عكس الدول العربيه يعني كما قال
بعضه من الدول العربيه الناس لا تريد ان
تتقاعد لانها بعد التقاعد تصبح معدامه في
كثير من الدول العربيه لانه التقاعد لا
يغطي سوى 30 لكن في الدول الغنيه الناس
تريد ان تتقاعد
الحكومات غير قادره على تلبيه ذلك كيف
يمكن تلبيه احتياجات الناس وايضا
يعني عاد سد العجز في صناديق التقاعد لدى
الحكومات التي تعاني من هذه المشكله
اول يعني اذا احنا بدنا نحل هذا الموضوع
يجب على جميع الافراد خلينا نحكي
الموجودين في العالم وفي لديهم وظائف
باماكنهم يعني في الدول الموجوده لازم
انهم يصيروا يشتغلوا على موضوع انه ما
يعني ما ينتظروا موضوع صناديق التقاعد ولا
يعتمد عليها بل يعتمدوا على انفسهم
ويعتمدوا على ما هم يعني في خلينا نحكي عن
نظريه اسمها ايكيجاي اللي هي نظريه
يابانيه يعني واضح جدا انها واثبتت
جدارتها
بالتواقع فعلي وليس فقط نظري وكلام بس
يعني هيك بالهواء بل هي نظريه اثبتت
جدارتها وقد يعني
قدرت انها توصل الاشخاص للمكان اللي بدهم
اياه كبار السن ما يعتمدوا على صناديق
التقاعد وما يكون في عمر معين انه يحسوا
فيه انه هم عايشين وبعد ذلك بنتظروا فقط
هو م الموت بعد هذا العمر فهذا هذا الشيء
هو الممكن يكون حل جذري لموضوع
الصناديق يعني خلينا نحكي
الباسور التقصير الحكومات بموضوع صناديق
ضاعت الكلمه فنادق
نعم الصناديق التقاعد فهي هون احنا بنقدر
انه نعدل هذا الشيء ونقدر انه نساعد
المتقاعدين او الكبار بالسن خلينا نحكي
على استكمال حياتهم بالطريقه الصحيحه
وبطريقه واضحه جدا وسهله وسهله
هناك من يتحدث مثلا عن نموذج يتم فيه
تمديد سن التقاعد على ان يتم تقصير سنوات
عفوا ساعات العمل وبالتالي يستطيع الانسان
ان يعطي اكثر ولكن بجهد اقل حسب قدرته
الجسديه هل نتحدث عن هذا النموذج هل نت
حدث عن نموذج النرويج الذي اشار اليه مؤشر
مثلا
نموذج تقصير ساعات الدوام هو بالفعل جدا
مجدي
وحتى اطاله فتره التقاعد او العمر
التقاعدي هون احنا ما عم نحكي على فقط
الحكومات احنا بنحكي عن الاشخاص والافراد
انفسهم اذا استمرت فتره
العمر التقاعد يعني اطاله فتره التقاعد
هون احنا عم نحكي عن تقصير الدوام اذا كان
الدوام او خلينا نحكي ساعات العمل اقل
فهون عم نحكي احنا عن تقليل مواضيع يعني
خلينا نحكي عن القلق
نحكي عن الاكتئاب خلينا نحكي عن حتى الصحه
النفسيه بشكل عام
للموظفين والانسانيه جمعاء انه اذا هم
قدروا انه نحن نخفف عنهم ساعات دوامهم
فاحنا راح نكون بصحه افضل حتى اطاله العمر
يعني الانسان بيكون بصحه افضل نفسيه
وجسديه وعقليه بتساعدوا انه يعيش فتره
اطول فهذا النموذج اذا احنا طبقناه في
دولنا العربيه وحتى بشتى انحاء العالم راح
يزيد من فعاليه
الانتاجيه للموظفين وراح يزيد من كمان
اطاله عمرهم وعدم اعتمادهم على صناديق
التقاعد بل انهم رح يكونوا يعني يقدروا
يتوصلوا لا الشغف اللي موجود عندهم
ويقدروا انهم يكملوا بالطريقه الصحيحه
الاهداف اللي بدهم اياها اللي هي انه شو
ما كان عمر التقاعد انا ما بحسن في الواقع
اثبتت
على الضمان او سوري
ساعات العمل لكن لمن تنادي واضح يا دكتور
دكتوره رولا يعني رغم الدراسات انه
للاسف صحيح صحيح لكن لا حياه لمن تولدي
لقد اسمعت لولديت حيا شكرا جزيلا
دكتوره رولا عواده اخصائيه هندسه بشريه
وموجهه شخصيه ومهنيه من عمان شكرا لك